lo que haremos en este vídeo será
abordar problemas que en su redacción
involucran razones aquí nos dicen que yo
da soda es una bebida de fiesta
intergaláctica que mantendrá a todos sus
amigos diciendo que bueno sabe esto
tienes una fiesta y necesitas 5 litros
de ayuda soda por cada 12 invitados
si tienes 36 invitados cuántos litros de
judas soda necesitas pausa en el vídeo y
traten de encontrar la respuesta bueno
nos dicen la razón de litros de refresco
por el número de invitados
necesitas 5 litros por cada 12 invitados
pero tienes 36 invitados
la razón es 5 litros de refresco por
cada 12 invitados pero estás en una
situación en la que tienes 36 invitados
esto es 3 veces el número de invitados
así que necesitas tres veces más litros
de refresco de modo que 3 por 5 es igual
a 15 5 a 12 5 litros para 12 invitados o
5 litros por cada 12 invitados es lo
mismo que 15 litros
cada 36 invitados así que para contestar
la pregunta cuántos litros de judas soda
necesitas necesitas 15 litros hagamos
otro problema aquí tenemos la imagen de
una pecera con muchos peces y nos dicen
que hay 8 peces grandes por cada espacio
peces pequeños y hay 4 peces grandes por
cada espacio peces pequeños pausa en el
vídeo nuevamente y traten de resolverlo
muy bien primero vamos a contar los
peces grandes 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 en esta
pecera hay 8 peces grandes y vamos a ver
cuántos peces pequeños tenemos 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 así que en la pecera por cada
8 peces grandes que podemos ver en rojo
hay 10 peces pequeños pero aquí nos
dicen que hay 4 peces grandes por cada
espacio peces pequeños
cuál será el resultado bueno una manera
de pensar en esto es que tenemos la
cantidad de peces igual a la mitad de
peces grandes así que dividimos entre
dos y vamos a tener la mitad de los
peces pequeños así que también dividimos
entre dos de modo que por cada cuatro
peces grandes tenemos cinco peces
pequeños otra manera de pensar en esto
es dividir los peces en dos grupos
iguales vamos a ver si podemos
capturarlos si pudiéramos dividirlos así
tendríamos de este lado uno dos tres
cuatro peces grandes y uno dos tres
cuatro o cinco peces pequeños y en este
grupo tenemos uno dos tres cuatro peces
grandes y uno dos tres cuatro cinco
peces pequeños de modo que para cada
cuatro peces grandes hay cinco peces
pequeños estas son razones equivalentes
continuemos
aquí nos dicen que una tienda de helados
utiliza los siguientes ingredientes para
hacer un postre de helado usan dos bolas
de helado cuatro cucharadas de chispas
dos cucharadas de crema batida cuantos
postres de helado hace la tienda si usa
32 cucharadas de chispas pausa en el
vídeo y traten de pensar en esto hay un
par de maneras de pensar en esto aquí
dice que estamos hablando de chispas lo
que es relevante de esto es que
necesitamos 4 cucharadas para cada
postre de helado así que podríamos decir
que la razón de cucharadas y postres de
helado es de 4 a 14 cucharadas de
chispas dejen de escribirlo así chispas
por cada postre de helado un postre de
helado pero nos dicen que estamos usando
32 cucharadas de chispas de modo que es
8 veces esa cantidad así que vamos a
poder hacer 8 veces la cantidad de
postres de helado tenemos 32 cucharadas
de chispas para cada 8 postres de helado
entonces cuántos postres de helado hace
la tienda si usa 32 cucharadas de
chispas hace 8 postres de helado
hagamos un último ejemplo en un parque
para perros hay 10 perros negros 5
perros cafés dos perros blancos y 12
perros de varios colores por cada perro
café hay dos perros espacio pausa en el
vídeo y traten de encontrar que debe
decir en este espacio muy bien hay 5
perros cafés por cada 10 perros negros 5
perros cafés por cada dos perros blancos
y 5 perros cafés por cada 12 perros de
varios colores pero aquí nos dicen que
por cada perro café hay dos perros
espacio entonces qué tipo de perros
tienen una razón tal que para cada perro
hay dos perros de ese tipo aquí vemos
que para cada cinco perros cafés hay
diez perros negros de modo que podemos
pensar que el número de perros negros
siempre va a ser el doble que de perros
cafés lo que significa que para cada
perro café hay dos perros negros una
manera de pensar en esto es la razón
entre perros cafés y perros negros que
es cinco perros cafés por cada diez
perros negros o si dividimos este número
entre cinco vamos a obtener un perro
café
por cada dos perros negros que es
exactamente lo que dice este enunciado
terminamos